If you look back on the car-park video, you'll see
it's very handy
Everything's cut and dried
Every possible combination of 20s, 10s and 5s
will work
get us to twenty-five,
deliver a ticket.
If we turn to what we were talking about briefly
at the end of that video
something like... I'm in a program language and I want
to declare an identifier name for my integers.
I want to call my integers 'sean' and 'dave', or even
'k9' as I said last time.
Well, they're fine. But if you want arbitrary-length
variable names,
How do you say
"I don't know whether it's going to be three letters long,
five letters long,
or even sixty letters long" ?
Maybe the compiler has an external limit anyway.
But, in general, how can we keep going around
without knowing how many?
And the answer, of course, is: Recursion.
I'm now going to draw you
a finite-state automaton diagram
for a programming identifier, yeah?
And those of you from Electronics Engineering
departments, you can say:
"Yes! We've known about these for years!
They're just state-machines."
So here comes a state machine for...
identifiers.
You have to have a starting point, we had
one in the car park
and we have to have one here, now.
And then, what I'm going to do
is to say
"Well, in order to get started on a programming
language identifier,
the rule is, you MUST start with a letter -
not a digit."
And i'll just denote any letter, for the moment, by L
This state here, which I'm calling the 'tailpiece' of the identifier,
is to take care of the fact
eventually,
that identifiers could just be a single letter.
Its perfectly possible to say "int i;"
[in the C language]
It's just a single-letter identifier.
So we've got to allow for that, it could be just one letter long,
or, it can be a letter
followed by ANY mix of letters and digits
in ANY order.
But eventually there has to be an end-marker.
And of course, typically, in the C programming language,
the end-marker is ; (semicolon).
Okay; how do we do that 'any-mixutre-of-letters-and-digits' stuff
Well, here's something new:
inside this 'tailpiece' state, I am saying
"You can go back into yourself...
by accepting more letters."
Down at the bottom I can say:
"Accept a digit..."
I'll call any digit just D at the moment.
So can you see whats happening here?
You go in, you MUST have an initial letter
but once you're in the "T" state
can come back into yourself!
And that is recursion.
But as you go back and come back into yourself,
you must accept a letter, or you must find a digit on
the input stream.
Eventually, the party's got to end;
you can't keep recurring for ever...
No good at all, you will crash!
You will run out of memory.
So eventually there's gotta be a way out of all this
morass.
And what I'm going to do, just so I can link up with
what Noam Chomsky did ...
The great Noam really liked to think of EVERYTHING
as a legal "sentence".
Let's call it S
We've mentioned this already that, you know, in car-park
language a legal
sentence is "10 10 5" because it adds up to 25, and so on.
But to get into this final state which sometimes
is called the "finish" state,
sometimes, equally, it's called the "accept" state,
then I need
to see
an E.
And an E is a valid end-marker.
And i'm saying that in... for this subset of the C-programming
language we're doing here
the end marker will be a ; (semicolon).
I might, later on, extend that a bit because if I do
some AWK examples
I want to be able to accept "newline" [\n]  as being
an end-marker as well.
But for the moment let's say yes, it's ; (semicolon)
So, that's it then!
That is a state machine.
The factor that's new in it, is the ability to do recursion.
for as long as you want, until you finally bottle out
of the whole thing,
and take the end-marker and say "that's the end of my declaration."
Okay!
Well, what emerged from all of this stuff about state-machines
and from Chomsky's work, in the mid to late 50's ?
For every machine you can draw,
like this,
and this is a MACHINE interpretation
of identifiers,
there's always a grammatical alternative.
And the more, if you like, mathematical-theoretician you are,
the more you like rather abstruse, so-called "top-down",
ways of thinking about things.
So, Chomsky's notation - let me just start you off on this, for this:
was to  say: Look, my goal is a sentence (S).
But what seems to be the case is that
to get to sentence (S), I've got to take
first of all an L, and then that gets me into a T state.
Okay...
Chomsky notation!
You can read the arrow as being "...is defined as".
A sentence...
is defined as...
an L,
any letter,
Followed by what I'll call a 'tail', or a 'tailpiece',
of the identifier - L and T.
Fine!
Well what... let's just do one example of what a T can be.
A T, look
Let's take this one.
Can be further defined as: yet another letter,
followed by another T.
Now look what's happening here, for the first time..
A rule for T is developing another visit into a T on
its right-hand side.
This is technically called Right Recursive.
And the Chomsky rules say you can be right recursive
If you want to do it the other way around, perversely,
and do T becomes T -> T L that's okay!
That's still within the Chomsky [Type 3] rules.
It can be purely right recursive, or purely left recursive.
I'll make it right recursive... it's a bit more intuitive to me.
And,just in case you think:
"Well, this is going to go on forever, and I can imagine
the T becoming a D T
and you're taking digits for ever...
What's the thing that gets you out of all this in the end?"
And the answer is - well - look back at the automaton
diagram and say "Ah!,
in the end you take the escape route!"
You take a T is defined as being an E
Thats one of the options. But what about E then?
Ah! well here's a classic example then,
of something that doesn't lead on to another rule,
it leads, in tree terms,
to a leaf of the tree - a terminal symbol that goes
nowhere else.
And what I'm hoping is there, is just a semicolon.
Of course you've spotted that the picture is completed --
refer back to the automaton again --
there's also a right-recursive option to say;
"Yes, accept any digit
and go back into T"
...so you go back into yourself again.
But equally you can now write at the bottom here --,
and it's in the handout --
we will do all of this in a linked handout --
So do read the Info block of this video. Find out
where the handout is,
download it,
read it.
You'll find in this complete thing
I've also said a letter can be anything
from a to z,  or A to Z
A digit can be anything from 0 to 9
That's the way you finish off that grammar.
This encourages you to think as computer scientists say:
top-down
You start with the purity of the abstraction of a "sentence",
and then you develop the detail below it.
Automata, really - I tried to show you the whole picture...
You can... for me, from an automaton, get a rather...
it's a bit top-down -- but you can always get more
of an idea of how
all this is built up in sequential steps going through it.
There's nothing very magic there now,
its just emphasising what I said at the start:
To every machine-picture of a circle in
the [Chomsky] hierarchy,
there is a corresponding
grammatical expression of it.
It's just as we'll go out through that Chomsky hierarchy
the machine interpretations become more complicated
and more involving of this magic thing called "memory",
as an ancillary to what state is your machine in.
Down here in type 3, where we are at the moment,
all we're saying is: "All you get is your states
and yes, you've got to model those correctly",
but you dont need ancillary memory for any purpose.
Later on, we'll find that we do.